the guts viola mine has been here for
decades producing lignite or brown coal
to fuel the nearby power station which
produces more energy than any other in
Germany a symbol of the country's
continuing dependence on fossil fuels in
2019 Brown coal and hard coal or
anthracite provided more than 29 percent
of the electricity used nuclear provided
14 percent renewables accounted for 46
percent but ministers are committed to
combating climate change by reducing
emissions and spent much of the last
year deep in discussions about how to
meet those commitments eventually they
found a compromise whereby both forms of
coal will be phased out within the next
18 years these were tough negotiations
they took a long time in my view too
long but you can see the result we're
the first country with a binding
agreement to exit coal and nuclear power
and that's an important signal
internationally felix mattis was a
member of the Commission which advised
the government to prioritize a steady
phasing out of coal he says they've not
taken that advice and broken their
promises in doing so they violated this
recommendation of the steady phase-out
the pathway at the moment is to wait
until the year 2030 and to wait until
the year 2038 and shut down the major
share of the lignite plant shortly
before these deadlines one of the
consequences of that will perhaps be
felt most here bear the hut
just down the road from gas viola with
the mines immediate future guaranteed
its owners want to expand it by buying
the properties in bear the hut
relocating the residence and then
destroying the houses to mine the coal
underneath already some people here have
taken the money and moved out but not
blitter Cox whose family has lived here
for six generations she is fighting to
stay we need to go back onto the streets
we must show people above all we must
show politicians that what they're
planning to do is absolutely mad we must
show them that we won't put up with it
ministers are clear that minds like
these will one day disappear and that
renewable sources of energy are the
answer the trouble for the people living
around here is their communities will
have to go first
and all despite the government stated
commitment to a green future
Dominic came al Jazeera GATS Valen